- [Voiceover] A circle
is centered on point B.
We see that right over there.
That's the center of
this big, blue circle.
Points A, C, and D lie
on its circumference.
We see that.
Points A, C, and D lie
on the circumference.
If angle ABC...
So ABC; So that's this
central angle right over here;
measures 132 degrees.
Alright, so this is 132 degrees.
What does angle ADC measure?
A, D, C.
So let's think about
how these are related.
ABC is a central angle.
ADC is an inscribed angle.
And they intercept the same arc.
The arc AC.
They both intercept this
arc right over here.
And we know from the
inscribed angle theorem
that an inscribed angle
that intercepts the same arc
as a central angle is going to
have half the angle measure.
And it even looks that
way right over here.
So if ABC-
if the central angle is 132 degrees,
then the inscribed angle
that intercepts the same arc
is going to be half of that.
So half of 132 degrees is what?
It is 66 degrees.
We can check our answer,
and we got it right.